en otros vídeos hemos hablado sobre la
ley de la demanda puede que esto sea
intuitivo para ti dice que si un
determinado producto se encuentra a un
precio más alto la cantidad demandada
será muy baja y luego a medida que el
precio disminuye la cantidad demandada
aumentará por lo tanto si tuviera que
graficar la demanda entonces así se
vería nuestra curva de demanda donde el
precio está en nuestro eje vertical y la
cantidad en nuestro eje horizontal este
es el estándar para la mayoría de los
economistas la curva de demanda tendría
pendiente negativa o descendente lo que
vamos a hacer en este vídeo es
profundizar un poco más en la razón por
la que tenemos esa curva de demanda con
pendiente descendente y sé que algunos
de ustedes están diciendo que esto tiene
sentido común a medida que el precio
baja querrás tener más de eso y del
mismo modo de casi todos los demás
bienes pero vamos a profundizar en la
razón por la que querrías tener más de
algo a medida que el precio baja por lo
tanto a una categoría de razones por las
cuales quisieras tener más de algo
el precio baja los economistas la llaman
el efecto sustitución efecto sustitución
y esta es la idea si miramos el precio
en relación con la cantidad por ejemplo
de dulces digamos que al principio el
precio está justo aquí en cuatro pesos y
en cuatro pesos la cantidad demandada en
el mercado sería digamos 100 unidades de
dulces tal vez 100 gramos de dulces si
el precio fuera dos pesos por alguna
razón digamos que el precio es de dos
pesos bueno entonces mucha gente podría
decir caramba el caramelo se ve mucho
mejor en relación con lo que podría
comprar con mi dinero así que por
ejemplo la gente podría estar escogiendo
entre dulces y frutas al principio ambos
cuestan 4 pesos por gramo o unidad pero
ahora de repente si el dulce es de 2
pesos por gramo o 2 pesos por unidad
bueno entonces se ve mucho mejor en
relación con la fruta de modo que un
poco de esa cantidad de frutas que la
gente habría comprado la sustituirán por
dulces y dirán que los dulces son
mejores
y es por eso que tiene una mayor
cantidad de dulces demandados esto
podría ser ahora de 250 unidades otra
categoría importante por la que
esperaría que esta curva de demanda
tuviera pendiente descendente para los
bienes normales y hablaremos de cosas
como los bienes inferiores en vídeos
futuros es el efecto ingreso el efecto
ingreso de alguna manera este efecto
podría ser el más intuitivo bueno si el
precio pasa de 4 pesos a 2 pesos el
costo de esas 100 unidades no sería la
mitad pasaría de 400 pesos a 200 pesos
por lo que el mercado tendría un extra
de 200 pesos para comprar cosas con esos
200 pesos extra comprarán más dulces y
también podrían comprar otras cosas
ahora la última dimensión de la que los
economistas hablarán para explicar por
qué la ley de la demanda tiene una
pendiente descendente como ésta y
hablamos de esto en otros vídeos es la
idea de disminuir y disminuir la
utilidad marginal y la idea es que la
gente que les da mucho valor tomara
primero los
que están en el mercado son adictos a
los dulces sus cuerpos dependen de ese
dulce pero tan pronto como esa gente se
sienta satisfecha la utilidad de la
siguiente unidad podría ser un poco más
baja y a medida que tengas más y más
dulces la utilidad marginal irá hacia
abajo y esa es otra forma de pensar
acerca de por qué tenemos una curva de
demanda con pendiente descendente hasta
el próximo vídeo